i'd like to thank mark for inviting me
to be part of this session to tell you
about our work with this cute little
yellow fruit which is golden berry and
we're also working with ground cherry
these are some points i'll cover during
my presentation i'll tell you about how
we got started working with the
fiscalists i'll then move on to talk
about the characteristics that need
improvement and these are being driven
by priorities for our nsf project and
also feedback from our community
scientists i'll tell you about how we're
fast-tracking improvement using crispr
cass and i'll talk a little bit about
our community science project where
we're engaging with farmers home
gardeners and various organizations to
get their feedback on the
characteristics that they feel need
improvement but to also familiarize them
with ground cherry and goldenberry
so how did we get started working with
the fistulas
well several years ago my collaborators
zach lipman and mike schatz and i had a
project where we were looking at
genes and networks involved in plant
growth habit fruit characteristics and
inflorescence architecture
we were using a reverse genetics
approach through crispr cast editing
and through this work we came to realize
that crispr cass could be a powerful
tool for fast-tracking improvement of
under-utilized species in a sense
fast-tracking domestication of
underutilized species so in our next
round of funding one of the aims was to
put that into practice we chose to stay
within the solanaceae as you'll see here
some of them and we wanted to work with
the fissilus because there was very
little if any improvement that has been
done and the fissilies you might be most
familiar with is tomatillo
however we chose to work with ground
cherry and goldenberry because in
addition to answering our basic
fundamental research questions we felt
there was potential for ground cherry
and goldenberry to be specialty fruit
crops in the u.s sometimes you'll see
ground cherry in the farmer's market
occasionally you'll see golden berry in
the grocery stores and people often ask
me what they taste like ground cherry
has a simple sweet flavor whereas golden
berry has a more complex flavor it's
sweet tart and some of our accessions
have undertones of coconut apricot and
mango
some characteristics of interest to us
it was that they're underutilized
they're more popular in other countries
colombia is the major producer of
goldenberry its
second
exports are second to banana from that
country and this image here is a photo i
took at a local grocery store and you
can see the golden berries were in with
other berries
they have a good nutritional content
vitamin c beta-carotene they also have
anti-inflammatory and antioxidant
properties which lend themselves well to
medicinal applications as they have been
used for centuries but not only ground
cherry and goldenberry other fistulas
have been used as well they also have
compounds for plant protection which are
with analytes and fasalins which have
steroidal properties
now move on to talk about
characteristics that need improvement we
have a list of characteristics that we
would like to target in the interest of
time i'll only be able to talk about
plant growth habit and the ground cherry
fruit size
most recently we've been working with
these insects uh chloridius subflexa and
three-line potato beetle because they
seem to be major pests especially on
golden berry
as for plant growth habit these this is
an image from our field these image this
photo was taken in july
you can see
how tall the plants are these stakes are
six feet from the top of the ground to
the top of the stake and you can see
already in july how tall they are by the
end of the season they grow over the
stakes we ended up having to trellis
them if you can see this twine here and
we use something called the florida
weave but you can imagine on a larger
agricultural scale this would be labor
intensive each year
as for ground cherry there's ground
cherries here in the foreground they um
the golden berries are in the background
so ground cherries don't grow as tall as
golden berries but they're a very
sprawling growth habit and again could
you know be a problem for farmers um
growing these and there's also a problem
with fruit drop
so the fruit dropped with underneath the
plant and i'm not going to talk about
that today but um our major target for
us is the plant growth habit
the next characteristics i'll talk about
is ground cherry fruit size we learned
through a consumer panel
evaluation that we did in cooperation
with cornell
that
the participants bought the ground
cherry fruit size could be would be
could be bigger um
and they thought that the size of the
golden berry would be a good size for
ground cherry so you can see the
different accessions we have here the
ground cherry size compared to some of
our our golden berries
so how are we using gene editing to fast
track this improvement well before we
could even start with gene editing we
had to work out a plant regeneration
system and then a plant transformation
method
we looked in the literature to see if
anything had been reported for ground
cherry and it hadn't we found reports
for um
tomatillo and for another fissilist but
those methods didn't work we chose to
start with ground cherry because it's a
diploid whereas golden berry as a
tetraploid and we felt that for the
editing work it would be much easier to
show that we were successful with
editing in a diploid than a
tetraploid at this point
so we um decided that since there
weren't any methods that were reported
and the methods we tried didn't work we
would just try our tomato method so what
we do is with the ground cherries we
germinate the seeds on this medium it
contains sucrose a gelling agent and
also salts to support plant growth after
seven to eight days you can see how tall
how big those um seedlings are we tried
the um
cotyledons and also the hypocotyl
sections the cotyledons didn't
regenerate but the hypocotyls as you can
see regenerated really well and this
medium contains zeotin as the plant
growth regulator
after about one month we can get rooted
plants from this stage and they root
readily there's no plant growth
regulators that are needed
we then take cuttings and move those
cuttings to test tubes and it's at this
stage that we'll take tissue and
evaluate those for the edits
once we have plants that we want to move
forward to the greenhouse we transfer
those to soil we use these plastic water
bottles you could also use plastic bags
we cut off the bottoms we like these
because they're reusable
and if we didn't do this the plants
would wilt and die and that's because
when they're in the test tubes it's a
really humid environment and the cuticle
hasn't developed the stomates are wide
open and you know again these would just
wilt and die if we if we moved them
right into soil without covering them
after a few days we removed the caps and
after a few days more we removed the
bottles and you can see um how big the
plants eventually get and then we move
these to the greenhouse or they get even
larger and we have a 100 success rate
with transferring our plants to soil
once we had the regeneration and
transfer to soil working we then moved
on to look at transformation and this is
work done by kerry swartwood we took
those hypocautical sections and we
infected them with the agrobacterium
strain agl1
our constructs all have the selectable
marker gene and pt2 which confers
resistance to canon myosin so we put
canon myosin in the medium to select for
plants that only contain our vector or
construct of interest and then again we
move those to soil
for working out the method we use a
green fluorescent protein construct i
really like
gfp for working out new systems because
unlike gus it's not destructive and we
can go back
to the different stages of gfp and just
follow that progress through and if it
doesn't look like we're seeing gfp at
one stage we then tweak that stage
to get more gfp expression
we take that construct we electroporate
it into agrobacterium and then we do the
transformation experiment this shows
some colonies in a plate of the
agrobacterium following electroporation
those colonies a couple of colonies are
then placed into this liquid bacterial
medium they're grown overnight and then
we read the od to make sure that it's at
the concentration that we need for doing
the infection
so we infected the hypocotyls and then
we looked for gfp a different
days post infection this stage is about
almost two weeks after infection and you
can see we're seeing green fluorescent
protein if we didn't see expression at
this point we would go back to that
agrobacterium phase and start tweaking
it by increasing the concentration of
agrobacterium and other parameters
that those little regions there then
grew into this green fluorescent callus
we saw shoots this is under um
white light bright field and then this
is under fluorescence and you can see
those little green sheets there
we transferred the plants to soil we
still saw the gfp expression when they
were making fruit i said to carry and go
out to the greenhouse and let's see if
they get some fruit and let's see if
they're expressing gfp and sure enough
they were we also saw gfp expression in
the husks and also in the seeds and you
can see expression here in the embryos
which was an indication that this would
persist to the next generation
once we had the method working
efficiently we then moved on to do gene
editing
and as you can see here we have that
npt2 to confer canon myosin resistance
the cas9 protein which does the
cutting of the dna is driven by the 35s
promoter and then we have our guide rnas
which are driven by the arabidopsis u6
promoter you really only need two rnrnas
to get edits but we really wanted to
knock out expression so we place our
guide rnas 50 to 100 base pairs apart
but what we have found over time is that
sometimes one guide rna works and the
other one doesn't even though we
followed all the guidelines so we we
save ourselves time by including two
sometimes we do four guide rnas um and
then if one or two don't cut we still
get edits um from other guide rnas
for the targeted traits of interest as i
mentioned i'm going to focus on just the
plant growth habit and the fruit size
and the interest of time so for plant
growth habit there are a number of genes
we could target but we'd start it with
this self-pruning gene and before i
start talking about self-pruning i need
to tell you a bit about
sympodial growth so many tomatoes you
know there if you grow them there are
these tall
continuing to grow indeterminate types
and then there are also more compact
determinant types well those
indeterminate types have this sympodial
growth that
what happens is you get these
sympodial units where you have three
leaves fruit three leaves fruit and that
will continue and that's because of this
gene called self-pruning which encodes
an anti-florigen or an
anti-flowering hormone
but in the 1920s a grower saw more
compact plants in his field and over the
years when those were characterized they
determined that they were mutants in
this sp gene and the hallmarks of sp
mutants is a determinate growth habit
burst of early flowering and these
shortened sympodial units and using this
material for breeding really
revolutionized commercial tomato
production so we wanted to recreate
those sp mutants in our ground cherry
and we
found the sp counterpart in ground
cherry and you can see here in red these
this is the sequence of our guide rnas
i'm just showing a few of our lines in
the edits you can see here this one has
a deletion this one has an insertion
and in this guy in our guide rna you can
also see there's some insertions and
deletions
so what we saw was very exciting this is
our wild type plant here on the far left
these stakes are about four feet tall
and you can definitely see a difference
in the plant growth habit of two of our
crispr lines we had others as well
as with all of our editing work we then
collect seed we look at the next
generation to see if the edits persist
and then we put those out in the field
and we continue to evaluate them for
other characteristics as well
as her fruit size again there are a
number of genes we could target we we
chose to start with clovada one and
clavado one works in concert with
another gene called wishel to keep shoot
meristem maintenance normal you could
imagine that loss of function would
increase that meristem size and also
increase floral organ number
well in our edited lines the first sign
that this was working was in the number
of petals so in the wild type you can
see there are five petals whereas in our
edited lines there are more petals seven
petals we also saw an increase in fruit
size this is wild type here these are um
fruit from our edited lines and we
actually saw a 24 increase in fruit
weight now as i mentioned before using
two guide rnas is helpful because in
this guide rna we didn't see any edits
but in this one here we did see edits
although you can't see those edits
because of my image
i'll try to move that later and you can
see it but again it was enough for us to
see edits and as with our other material
we're putting these to the next
generation and making sure that it
persists and we haven't negatively
affected any other characteristics
i'm going to move on just to tell you a
little bit about our fiscalist
improvement project the purpose of this
is to engage with farmers home gardeners
and various organizations
we're using this information to guide
our crop improvement but we also want to
heighten the visibility of ground cherry
and golden berry for specialty fruit
crops
we have a website if you're interested
in
following along just search for a
fissilist improvement project you can
subscribe to our blog
i have a twitter account and we also
have an account for the fiscalist
project and we're using this as a
platform to also communicate about crop
improvement methods including gene
editing and genetic engineering
so in summary crispr cast is a powerful
tool but do we need it all the time no i
think i can get concern
especially the younger generation gets
enamored with new technology
we don't always need crispr but it
certainly can help um in plant breeding
our first modifications that we did this
sp in clovada one took just two years
and that included developing the
transformation method so our end goal is
to create variation for the traits of
interest to have enhanced germplasm that
can be used in breeding programs we're
now moving on to goldenberry and for
ground cherry and goldenberry we have
these new directions one of those i
mentioned is looking at insect
interactions and we're going to we've
started looking at metabolites that
could be possibly involved
with those interactions
for on with that i'd like to thank the
members of my group i'd also like to
thank our greenhouse group brian joe and
jay for growing beautiful plants for us
my collaborators zach lipman mike schatz
our community science participants our
funding agencies because without them we
wouldn't be able to do the work and i'd
like to thank you for attending my
presentation and i'm happy to take
questions now